let's do a little bit more practice with
our trigonometric ratios or
trigonometric functions
so here we're asked to find the values
of cosine of theta and sine of theta so
let's start with cosine
cosine theta
what is the cosine of theta where theta
is this angle right over here and it is
indeed a right triangle so i'll give you
a few seconds to think about that
well to answer this you just have to
remember the definitions of the trig
functions and to help us there we will
use the mnemonic
kato and the part of sohcahtoa that
relates to cosine is the cup part this
tells this defines sine that's why we
have the s this defines cosine that's
what starts with the c this defines
tangent that's why it starts with the t
so if you look at k it says that cosine
let me do that same color
it says that cosine of an angle
cosine of an angle is equal to the
adjacent side
adjacent side over
the hypotenuse so in our example here
what is the adjacent side
well if we look at it it's the side
that's next to it that is not the
hypotenuse
this side is next to it and it's not the
hypotenuse this side up here is next to
our angle but it is the hypotenuse it's
the one that's opposite it's opposite
the right angle so this is the
hypotenuse
hypotenuse up here
this is for
if we're looking at angle theta this is
the adjacent side
and while we're at it if we want to
think about the opposite side we don't
have to deal with it for cosine but it
doesn't hurt to label it right now that
is the opposite and this is relative to
angle theta so that out of the way we
said cosine of theta is equal to json
over hypotenuse adjacent has length four
adjacent has length four
what is the hypotenuse well we know what
side is the hypotenuse but they haven't
given us the length yet
but we can figure it out using the
pythagorean theorem we have two sides of
a right triangle we can always figure
out the third side we know
that the sum of the squares of the two
shorter side is going to be
will be equal to the square of the
hypotenuse
so we have
4 squared
plus
7 squared
7 squared is going to be equal to
i'll just call it h squared or
hypotenuse squared is going to be equal
to 8 squared
so 4 squared is 16
7 squared is 49
plus 49 it's going to be equal to 8
squared
and let's see 16 plus 50 would be 66 16
plus 49 is 65
so this right over here is 65 h squared
is equal to 65
or we could say that h is equal to the
square root
of 65 and it doesn't look like there's
any perfect squares in here 65 is 13
times 5 neither of those are perfect
squares so this is about as simplified
as we can get this radical so the
hypotenuse is equal to the square root
of 65. so in this case cosine of theta
is equal to the adjacent side
which has length 4 over the hypotenuse
which has length square root of 65. now
let's do the same thing with the sign
what is the sine of theta going to be
and i'll give you a few seconds to think
about it
well so tells us that sine
is equal to opposite
over hypotenuse
in this case relative to angle theta the
opposite side has length seven has
length seven and what is the hypotenuse
or what is the length of the hypotenuse
well we just figured it out it is the
square root
square root of 65.